do you think about the election result
in
the fantastic outcome of the direction
10% for momentum into seats nobody
really like is the fact that in this
election more Europeans to parts that in
the previous election that's a great
great signal for European democracy
[Music]
well we always always knew was going to
be a tough election and I think it is
clear that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so sorry for this delay ladies and
gentlemen all the poll stations across
the European Union are officially closed
since 11 p.m. as I have already
mentioned the preliminary turnout
estimates are very positive our
estimates now show for the whole
European Union 28 member states
including the United Kingdom that fifty
point five percent of voters across the
Union turn out to vote this is eight
points higher than in 2014 when tunnel
had stabilized for the first time again
these figures are the highest of the
past 20 years and represent the first
significant increase in turnout since
the first elections in 1979 this is in
some way which shows that the European
citizens realized that the European
Union is part of their everyday reality
and their future this time they voted
and ladies and gentlemen this concludes
this unique transnational Democratic
exercise we are now able to update our
seat projections based on a mix of final
results provisional results and in a few
cases exit polls and estimates and I'm
going to read out these results that of
course will be updated also in the next
minutes and hours European People's
Party 178 178 socialists and Democrats
152 152 European conservatives and
reformists 6161 Alliance of liberals and
Democrats plus three national
party's 108 108 the United Left Nordic
Green left 39 39 greens European free
Alliance 67 67 seats European Europe for
freedom and direct democracy EF DD 53 53
Europe of Nations and freedom 55 55
seats non-attached members 7 others 31
ladies and gentlemen the citizens of the
appian union have chosen who will
represent them in the European
Parliament this will have a direct
impact on who will head the European
Commission over the next legislative
term as members of parliament will be
those who will take the decision in
stressful in July I would therefore like
to invite the candidates for the
presidency of the European Commission to
make a short reaction to these
preliminary results follow of course by
a few questions and starting from the
European People's Party candidate
Manfred bevel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so good evening ladies and gentlemen
first of all the most important outcome
of today's or the last 4 election days
is for me that the European democracy is
alive we have a turnout of about more
than 50% and there is a great victory
for the European democracy people voted
people decided about the future of our
continent and there is great I want to
thank all my my friends who also run in
the European elections the competitors
from the Socialists run Zimmerman's from
the Greens
ska Keller but I could from the all the
other political families who had Spitz
in Canada I think we showed the fair and
the Democratic competition and that
brought again this idea of European
democracy alive you know that I myself I
fight a thought and fight for a European
Parliament which is center of the
European political development that we
decided the European Parliament about
the main lines for the future of Europe
and that is said ideal is today strongly
strengthened the second element the
second outcome is we are facing a
shrinking center of the European
Parliament the center of those parties
who believe in the future of Europe who
wants two drinks in Europe who wants to
have an ambitious approach for the
future of Europe that is what we are
facing a shrinking centre for the EPP
today's feeling is not a feeling of
first of all of victory because we are
losing seats what we can say is that we
are happy to be again the first group in
the European Parliament to be the
biggest group to be in the first row
that is what we are happy about but
again we also see that we lose seats I
promised in the European election
campaign
I promised stability when you vote for
if you vote for an EPP party on European
level you will get finally a group who
is ready to create stability
and having this in mind I see a few let
me say steps ahead of us one element is
that I want to clarify that for the EPP
for the European People's Party there is
no chance for any cooperation no bill no
readiness for any cooperation with
extremists from the raft and from roots
from the riders ettus during the
campaign several times for us I can
really say there will be no cooperation
with any party who don't believe in the
European spirit in the future project of
European Union a second element for this
stability is that we want to invite to
talk now about the content about the
mandate for the next five years what
people have told us during the campaign
must now be included in a mandate for
the future project of the European Union
for the next five years on European
level for us it's also clear that we
stick to the idea of spits in Canada
there will be no support for any other
candidate then a candidate who presented
his program his profile and his
personality before the people went to
vote and when we speak about stability
then there is no maturity no stable
majority against the EPP possible and
having in mind that CPP is today the
strongest group obviously when we look
to the figures let's see about the final
outcome then we have also a leading
function in this and finally to give you
an idea what are the next steps now from
our point of view the first step is that
in the next upcoming days the European
Parliament should again confirm that we
stick to the schvitz in Canada at
concept EPP is ready to do so I hope
others will also follow and the second
is that we create the mandate among the
pro-european parties the content the
project for the future and this project
can be finally also discussed with the
council you know that the council is
discussing about strategic guidelines
for the future and I hope that
can combine the mended of European
Parliament together with strategic
guidelines of the Council to bring it
together to merge them and to have a
proper idea for what is now to do for
the next five years on European level so
for me the most important messages stop
crisis times top stop crisis thinking in
Europe and let's start with an
optimistic perspective for a Europe
which can show to the citizens we can
achieve so much together if you work
together and secondly start a Europe of
people I want to start a commission of
the people that is what we as EPP fought
for and we have amended for this thank
you we'll have time for some questions
now from the Financial Times mr. Weber
given the Liberals and give offs that
have been the most vocal opponents of
the spits and candid art system and
including the French president tonight's
numbers show that you could have a
majority a stable alliance that doesn't
include all the the Liberals or Marsh
are you willing to entertain the idea of
having a tripartite coalition without
the Liberals when I look to the figures
then I don't see a majority against
liberals I don't see a majority against
socialists I don't see a majority
against CPP so what I would ask us to do
is to join our forces to work together
from now on
soos again who believe in the spirit of
an ambitious Europe of an ER approach X
of a Europe which concerns the people
that didn't serve interest it is in
their interest to have a strong European
Union those politicians must work
together from now on we showed people
alternatives during the campaign that is
a normal thing there is a good things
there is a healthy thing in a democracy
but from now on those who wants to have
a strong European Union has to join
their forces and that is again my
invitation to the socialist liberals and
also to the Greens because having the
figures in mind the greens are also the
winners of the day that's why again the
greens are possible partners I think we
should sit together and should define
now
the mandate for the next five years your
political group remains the biggest one
but you also lose a lot of seats and
what's your message to the leaders in
the council and this is weaken your
chances for the top job in the European
Commission well when you refer to the
outcome of my party my biggest message
is first of all that I want to thank
those who voted for us a lot of people
in the European Union voted for us and
that is what I have in mind and again
what we will divide is this
democratization this parliamentary
session of the European Union when
people take it serious the European
elections then the leaders should also
take it serious
what happens today that is what I am
asking for and having these democratic
principles in mind I think those who
will finally have to join together have
to find a common understanding for the
future Suz parties have to respect who
is number one who is number two is the
number three in the question who is has
finally the reading leading role again
for us I don't I don't feel a real
powerful victory today I can only say
that I am happy that we arrived as a
strongest political family that is a big
achievement that was our main goal when
we started our campaign to arrive again
as a group who can ask for the right to
lead but we are open for all the other
contributions we are open for content
and we are open for other contributions
when it is about the distribution of the
posts on European level last one taste
of you Christmas
a Polish press agency the question about
the hungers feeders did you have a
opportunity to talk with talk with mr.
Viktor Orban or are you going to talk
with him because without him the leaders
position my might change take into
account the Socialists might be joined
by Vyasa from Poland and syriza from
from from Greece and if it happens are
you ready to support mr. Kamura months
for missing candidate and pre-candidate
thank you well for the moment the EPB is
with around 26
what were the latest figures 26 seats
ahead as biggest political family in the
next European Parliament that answers
the question on fitness
so the EPP is the strongest political
family in the European Parliament in the
upcoming Parliament and that's why for
us it's a key question to join again
those who really believe in the future
of the European Union thank you very
much thank you so much thank you good
and now we move to the socialists and
Democrats group and the candidate mr.
France timmermans will take the floor
right now
[Music]
[Music]
good evening let me start with a big
shout out to the millions and millions
of Europeans who took the trouble in the
last couple of days to go out and vote I
think it's a good sign for European
democracy that more people turned up
than many many years before I also
believe people understand this is also
my experience traveling around Europe in
the last couple of months that their
lives that destinies are intimately
linked with the choices we make in the
European Parliament's in the European
Commission and the council so here we
are voters have spoken citizens have
spoken the result is clear first of all
let me congratulate those who have one
additional seats in this Parliament well
done I also have to say that as you know
and as you will certainly remind me of
my political family has lost seats we
have lost seats and this means that we
have to be humble we have to be clear
what our program is going to be but I'm
also optimistic optimistic on the basis
of what I've heard across Europe in the
last couple of months people want us to
do something about the climate crisis
urgently people want us to make sure
that social injustice is also tackled at
the European level people want us to
make sure that big corporations finally
start paying fair taxes and people want
us to make sure that we can work
together with fellow Europeans to solve
the problems that we can no longer solve
only at the national level that is why I
will repeat my proposition to work with
other progressive parties in this
Parliament to try and build a program
that addresses the aspirations the
dreams and also sometimes the fears
about fellow Europeans
we create a platform on the basis of
progressive politics forward-looking
dynamic stability is not the first word
that comes to mind when I think of
Europe stability means keeping things as
they are I don't think that's what
Europe needs Europe needs to dynamically
look towards the future and take the
necessary steps to bring that future
closer this is what new we need to do
this is what people ask of us and if we
deliver on these points then we can show
that progressive constructive
cooperative politics delivers results
and that nationalism only delivers fears
and hate so once again my offer is on
the table let's sit together with
progressive forces in this Parliament
let's try and find a program for the
next five years that will prepare Europe
for the 30 years to come thank you very
much to everyone who took the trouble to
go and vote thank you and we have time
for a couple of questions if we start
with Christophe Schmidt from throw
anybody think it's just meat from the
Dutch newspaper trail given the fact
that both the EPP and the snd lost seats
in more or less the same proportion
which is a important signal from the
from the voters how can you possibly
claim or put a bigger claim on the
Commission presidency than mr. Webber
first of all I'm not putting any claims
at all you're right to say that these
two parties who have always had a
majority in European Parliament now for
the first time both lost so that we no
longer have a majority but in that sense
the European Parliament is a perfect
reflection of what happens in most
member states this is also the situation
in most of our member states it has
become more difficult to form
coalition's that's why I think you know
I'm not claiming anything I'm I think
you know if you lose an election if you
lose seats you have to be modest but at
the same time you also have to take the
responsibility because we still have
more than 150 seats in this Parliament
this new Parliament that gives us a huge
responsibility to do something positive
for European society in the next five
years
and to do that we will need to build
coalitions and on the basis of a program
and the coalition then we can start
playing the game of thrones on who gets
which job but that's the right order
that's why I'm not claiming anything I
hope I can bring together a coalition
with a program we need for the next 5
years and then we will see who can lead
that in the European Commission okay
thank you very much I have Christophe
from the Polish press agency running to
the microphone Thanks I think you said
that stabilities then not the first
thing which comes in mind when you are
thinking about that Europe doesn't mean
that you are rolling out cooperation
with the EPP because mr. Weber just said
that this stability is needed my worry
is that whenever I hear Weber or the EPP
talk observe stability they mean let's
keep things how they are that I think if
you look at the result of the election
it's not an option so I want to work
with parties who understand that we need
to make some really bold decisions on on
the climate crisis on social injustice
on the need to transform our economy
into sustainably economy on the need to
tax companies that don't pay tax today
and anyone from a Democratic Party that
shares these ideas I want to talk to and
try and build a coalition with the only
ones I've said all along the campaign I
don't want to work with his extreme
right I will never have an agreement
with them because we don't share the
vision of Europe and we don't certainly
don't share the vision of humanity and
humanism so I could never enter into an
agreement with them but all the other
parties of this share our vision of a
progressive Europe that really needs to
take step forwards now forward now I
think I will work with okay and we'll
just take one final question from Thomas
Meyer from the stander good evening mr.
two moments I think there apparently you
don't like the word claim but I think
there are millions of Europeans tonight
who want to know who will be the next
president of the
would you perhaps prefer the sentence
that I want to become president of the
European Commission and a second
question if I may
if we look to the figures there the
rainbow coalition is apparently very
close to a simple majority which is
necessary to vote for the next president
in the Parliament we know that mr.
McCrone has doubts on the system of
splits and candidates what would you do
in the next days and weeks to convince
mr. McRoy and the majority of the head
of states who've nominate the next
president of the Commission thank you
the first part of your question mr.
Maier I would say I would wager that the
vast majority of European citizens
aren't that interested who's going to
lead the next Commission are more
interested into water is that Commission
going to do what is are they finally
going to do for us to tackle the climate
crisis to do something about social
injustice etc and then if you have a
good program then I think we need to
find an agreement who could lead that
program I would be honored to lead that
program but in that order so yes of
course it's interesting to write about
this and to talk about this but frankly
I believe also after having campaign in
so many member states that citizens are
more interested or what are you actually
going to do for us in the next five
years and on the second part of your
question we will need a majority in the
European Parliament and would I if I
look at the figures now I understand why
month for Weber says stability because
he also sees that there is a possibility
of a majority without VBP now I'm not
saying there should by definition be a
majority without the EPP I'm only saying
in a democracy it is healthy that non
not one party is is unavoidable in a
majority so I'll be looking for a
progressive majority to do the things
that our citizens
expect from us and if that is with
people who understand which are the
subjects we need to tackle to understand
the seriousness of the climate crisis
and are prepared to take the necessary
measures I take them from any anywhere
except as I said from the extreme right
but let's see if we can build a majority
on the base of that program for the next
five years thank you thank you very much
thank you very much thank you very much
and now on behalf of the alder party
Margaret the vest hugger
[Music]
congratulations to each and every one of
you who has voted in this election and
shown the European support for having a
European democracy this is that landmark
more than 50% not four decades
have we seen such a turnout and that I
think is for everyone no matter where
you are in this an election no matter
your party results but you congratulate
each other for the turnout so many
distractions on a Sunday the beach the
couch fun things to do and yet more than
50% of Europeans turned out to say we
live in a democracy power is voting and
they did thank you very much
and I think this is a signal for change
because you see how the Parliament has
changed its composition this is not
anymore just a two-party majority this
is a new Parliament this is the wins of
the new liberal group of local public or
Marsh is a please it's the magnifica
you see this the strength now coming in
and you see the winds of the greens but
you see that climate change and the
consciousness that we need to do
something that is for real and that is
very promising for the new European
Parliament so new coalition's can be
built for those who want to embrace
change and obviously the third important
thing to note is that we can show change
by having the first gender balanced
Commission because then people can
mirror themselves as who we are as
Europeans women and men
making sure that we take action to fight
what we don't like and to embrace all
the opportunities that comes from living
in Europe thank you thank you very much
and as you all know by now we have the
opportunity to take three questions
three questions that we'll start right
here in Brussels with political and my
adorable thank you thank you very much
mrs. vista ger given the score tonight
does it give the Liberals a claim for
the EU top jobs and the second question
is how do you see this future
progressive majority and with whom with
the EPP for example thank you I think it
is obvious I have I have worked with
breaking monopolies this is basically
why I've been doing for five years by
now and this is also what voters have
been doing today the monopoly of power
is broken and this is of course why we
can do something else
and I very much appreciated it was my
colleague Francie moment just said that
a coalition can be built of those who
wants to do something of those who want
to take action progressively to change
things and if you look at the signals
coming from green saying well actually
Albert has responded we can do things
differently I think there's room for
talks in the coming days that are
different from what we saw before and
also for a different composition of
leadership in the different institutions
so indeed yes and the second question is
from Zeus's item and catalyzes most of
the other parties have decided who would
be the schvitz in Canada a long time ago
whereas you only claim tonight for the
very first time but yes you do want to
be a next Commission president so I have
two questions the first is why did you
say that you news agencies before and
not now on the stage and the second is
how do you want to convince the other
parties who have like Madiba just did
said to only vote for Schmidt some
candidate who has like claim to be
written candidate before the election so
how do you want to convince those
parties to give you their voices and
votes first of all I find it's very
awkward not to answer a question when
you're being asked so this is why I
thought it would be awkward to wait so
I'm here and anyway it was part of the
news when I was here the last time with
all colleagues in in this process to say
well yes I am indeed here because in my
experience you never get anything if you
don't ask for it the worst thing that
can happen is that you get a no course
it hurt your vanity but you live the
second thing is that for for us it's
important that the two institutions they
Co decide because this is also our
identity our directly elected
representatives and as said the
Europeans have come out tonight
so strongly for that but also how we see
ourselves as citizens and it's in every
member state and for the next five years
the council and the Parliament it will
have to work together and this is of
course why it's so important that they
also work together in deciding on the
leadership of the future because then
you get a starting point that is
promising for getting results in the
next five years to come and that balance
reflecting our identity how Europe has
been built and also a working
relationship of the future that is what
has been important for us and this is
why we have engaged so much on substance
to get the votes out to make sure that
people see well who is who in Brussels
is for after the election before the
election it's about how to fight climate
change how to get in control of
technology how to create societies where
each and every one of us feel counted in
and that has been our preposition in
this campaign and as you see on our
numbers I think this has been heard by a
lot large large part of the voters thank
you very much and the third and final
question is from the Finnish broadcaster
Houla please Thanks better idea Finnish
national broadcaster
you seem to be in a pretty good
bargaining position when you look at the
chart there what is the number one thing
that you want to use that leverage for
to advance in in your talks or in all
this talks with with these other parties
Thanks well the most important thing is
change so that we enable us to take
action the commission that I've been
part of has prepared so many things with
the Parliament and with Council the
redesign of our energy markets being
ready to be implemented to enable us to
do a lot more efficiently with climate
change issues what has now been passed
and proposed to deal with technology is
work in progress but pushing there and
of course when it comes to tax justice
now I think is a very important point to
make sure that all the many many
businesses who pay their taxes they see
that also those who don't pay today they
are parts of contributing to the
societies where they do a very very good
business so I think on substance we have
a number of things that will enable a
broad coalition not in every detail for
the next five years but on some of the
fundamentals and that of course
including rule of law freedom of the
press gender equality and equality as
such thank you very much thank you okay
and now we'll be time for the Greens
party in this case with the two
candidates Scott Keller and bass takeout
please be aware that we are updating
right now our provisional resource thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much and good evening or
good night it is by now first of all
from our side we want to thank all the
voters coming out but especially of
course the voters who are very clearly
asking for change asking change for a
new Europe a Europe that is fighting
climate change a Europe that is looking
for a green transition in a socially
just way and a Europe that is fighting
for the rule of law and fighting to
uphold the democracies in all the Member
States and that is a Europe that has
been voted for and where we as greens
have been performed even better than the
polls have predicted and that is really
something that we are very thankful for
I think very grateful and we see it also
as a very important responsibility to
live to deliver on that in the coming
five years thank you and this
responsibility that is something that we
want to carry through in every action
that we do in the European Parliament
we have been campaigning on climate
protection on biodiversity protection
but also on a social Europe and making
sure that civil liberties are being
upheld all over the European Union also
in countries such as Hungary and this is
something that we want to do and put now
into practice in the European Parliament
the European Parliament is the place to
for example work on climate protection
because the climate does not stop at the
borders and we have seen that this is a
great concern for citizens all over the
European Union so we will not in this
Parliament get around that issue as
Greece we certainly don't want to get
around this issue but it's also clearly
a call to other parties and groups to
take that issue seriously and not any
more obstruct votes on climate justice
as they have done in the past five years
and even before so for us it's a very
clear task for us to do now in the
coming weeks month and years and I would
just like to join and thanking the green
voters it's been really amazing also to
see that sometimes ways were maybe not
so much predicted to scores
well and maybe other stories have been
more interesting but we see that it
works to have a positive vision for the
European Union and that has gained a lot
of support thank you very much for that
thank you very much we're just gonna
open the floor up to three questions now
we could start over here with euronews
which issues will you put forward to
consider joining a coalition and a
second question will you give your vote
only to a split some candidate are you
ready to give a vote to someone outside
the splits and candidate process thank
you well first of all what we will see
now for the first time is that there
will be really negotiations on the
program for a new European Commission
and we have been campaigning the entire
months and that we have done we have
been campaigning on climate action
social justice and democracy so those
three topics will also be at the
negotiation table from a green
perspective and we will make our demands
there and we will make very clear that
any new president of the Commission
needs to come very clear on these topics
and deliver change and then on your
second question on the pits and
candidates it is very clear this is
important to improve democracy if you
see the higher turnout is also a higher
turnout for the European Parliament
making very clear that what we are
delivering is a new European Commission
and a new president and so from our
perspective we will go for people that
were already in the race before the
elections that they are also after the
elections and we will support only those
candidates that have been running during
the campaign we've got time for two more
open questions if you'd like to open
answer and to ask a question please come
up to the mic
okay thank you very much thank you what
I am a nonce about LeMans and all
opportunity they could
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
Thank You Niko commerce' if there are
questions could people step up to the
microphones yes please step up to the
microphone Thanks hello Catherine Curie
reporter lost a number of seats and I
appreciate that that's disappointing
but will you be throwing your weight
behind a Progressive Alliance and your
conditions be thank you okay any further
questions to step up to the microphones
all right thank you very much thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
but there was also a stronger say on
[Music]
allora Bonasera Bonasera to to intervene
God s own honest on take la Provenza Oh
the wingull a super ghetto managers on
the Italian Aikido and Oliver are you in
DG tengo de primo party todo esto pasa a
ingre CRA horn a koozie finalmente
si puede hacer ahora perto senseiess ray
a Casati de Valera's true mental is re
quindi Camilo fatto per kg credible G
credo is she credible prima del voto
secreto that one in Avanti ringrazio GJ
la su a Nona you tomatillo salvinia la
liga a Yuta l'Italia la ropa a little
air Esperanza or goleo radicchio lavoro
cigarettes opinion on Maya feed at o al
Cory Mac alot o di maria un modo all
such as sodium party tome alpha 2 rho el
destino de un país é doom continent a
yachty sedan or a Joan a la Festa dura
pokey minuti percale momento de la
responsibility' me leonid italiana
channel feed a to la misión histórico
reporter el centro del de batty to repay
or is delete olive or older ito la
salute el delito la vita delito de la
familia metal mundo de delito de rigazzi
esperar in moola Boros tabula un such a
so incredible a non so local Oh De La
Liga in Italia solo cinque an ephah age
or nollie par la bonne o una liga in via
deist in Sione's SOC amo primo partito
an order a pseudo abbiamo percent wali
soap religion quanta % o in trans DC
meseta se llaman k primo partito in
tanta cheetah del centro del sol de
hecho Metron Cora pew energiya an hora
pew pacion ancora PMP no non so la la
liga prio parte de natal a marine lepen
a primo party 10 ropa
in France and Nigel Farage a prio party
to Ingram Britannia Quinn D Italia
francha in gilt era el signo de europa
que cambia CS to fat belly ropa surveyed
a patella 40 del elite della finanza
della multinational indeed a domani in
nostro lavoro rod OPA tiempo del fest
Elemento a poco a quasi finito do Rallo
spazio di una sirata n Gasol italiani
Caggiano so stay new T Cointreau to toe
e 2t estate owned a company Terada
Kayoko me secretary della Diego mean
stolen intern o visu token passione con
or go leo Cana tacky quoted Yanni ever
gone Oh sí pero la vita reali
a p40 Delia tacky vr-2 a leak in the
museum o Questacon sense in nome para
regula mentally content any mi obverse
REO era era mani la sinistra ka govern a
tamale in italia in europa yeti governo
permesso Noemi she con cuidado man ec
torn Oliver re Serena meant a Abbess
angry tone y'know my response to Nelly
will team SAT man Elliot a key like
windy cone to the render in mono domain
Matina contrato de governor aplicar e2
TT Maggiore must in so spezzo Larry
Delta se la autonomia decreto cigarettes
ax le grand e opera blow cotta ill de
kratos blocka can thierry de great okra
schita he sustained yo a disabled
missus 10 yo la familia sera UN período
economic o complicate o lo dico a little
yari Raquin ECMO perfectamente con
sapele delhi difficult a hospital
siamo primo party todo un grande paisa
even delhi mode if our Valley arena Poli
Rajani questo grande pies Leone Delhi
comprend into italiani do pará italiani
de medici Tagliani
Billy agriculture italiani report and in
Europa in Dorito lavoro Dorito la vita
delito cigarettes a monkey valerie
apron cheapy qualcuno a nagato le ready
go crystianna del oro payaso status
buffet Giotto / k y OG domani prover ah
testimony ra con lavoro call IATI
connelly operate una fille de un futuro
me Laura his pet oak well okay in
bureaucratese Bank Erie or pea no
preparado windy so no Felicia point on
saucier resultado final de la liga Sarah
Trent Alvin Tino Beltran - no ill Vento
told treinta - no party ahmad al say
perch in toda synchrony final ditches
set a percent o le unnie's course she
goes tree sherry pay Tony single vote
okay little Yael italiani cha know that
Odin order sued nan Vera da may use ATO
perky dairymaids apple troll impugn
Italia Vera da know use ATO / probe Aria
can be re a salvar a leopa a quiero que
el regalo Pavano can be aa TV colleano
Pavano can be Otte lost I Rita lop Rica
Rita Lodi Zoku passione elevate leave
LOD beat appear in Austria got see non
posso no P over m scene so if windy come
to the Avera Aliotti
in French and German in hasta la Londe
in belljo in gram battalions vet say in
Finlandia Peron footer of on dato
sullivo rose we dear it is Roz / Anza
sulla salute a quarter a mofo dotty del
Alessio Nico moon Ali yo Manny Sora in
official mr. del internal ringrazio to t
president is a Jo to Tillis Goethe Tory
to t represent on TV lista - telly Don
you owe me della Fort Seddon Lord in a
yeah no guarantee tone a competition a
sauna Coretta Leal a party she pata
chala no don t come unique and renewal
below Todd Joe doe Veda same prey
governor valise in astray finalmente
dope OD Cheney Saguna posited I cam be
amento attend oka Nancy Yankee Dottie
dal Arizona piemonte repeat Oh c'est la
liga and I'll go very Johnny p.m. on te
quiero que serán masaccio a favor dela
prosecution a conclusion Adela grandia
opera a bian que estan vote O'Dell
italiani Parisi parasya lavoro policía
de rio celeste hace para sierra del
formal giustizia per se are informal
squall
there is Sierra form a fiscal I'm in the
questi me Leone devotee K Mira Pagano
Damacy the empanada fatty kadhi passione
sacrificiai Manoj real tragedy Bujji I
didn't shed approaches C Madonna for
saying credi be the quindi ring rasool
italiana cameo fiduciary Gasol italiani
Anka Canova taught over to tal tree a
con toda Russia rapper Larry uncle
italiana italiana Kanaan a no vote at o
ver que cuando Quattro jitteriness ehe
she'll go ravine on Shelly revenant
Ament a to t de bono farah called Casa
de PUE a call cause edema Leo Quinn
deeper color girl guarda may mr. De La
Liga parliamentary delaware natori de la
liga scene - e de la Vega domani mattina
siamo in official friend Tonto permit a
team in the opposite team an MSD
Battaglia complicated army in Paree
my permit led La Senza doler many sins
affair como se llama la noche ng Nadar
me in pari contro quasi to tow a to t
Lunik apology my scent OD eyelash are a
little quest anata Grazia Grazia /
Cavuto fiducia loser a mo al me leo
questa fiducia Repetto nam Perego
lamented ican't in turn in western a
political Vecchia provincial a super
oughtta Yunnan Kido Meza patron and peu
mezzo ministro in pew mezzo sotto
Sagittario president in pew Kido solo
una generación sulit ratio del programa
de Guevara me notice F India voke
tsunami enter Oliva es una patrimony
aller sous la casa su econ teacher NT
elbow toe do G XI D XI que cambian
O'Leary goalie della ropa no solo per se
today italiana McHale shelter D
franchisee
/ shelter a today s keeper shell today
in glazy / shell today younger AC /
shelter a pole a keeper shell today
Finland Daisy
well shell today is bidets Eden se
quindi anatta / grappa Elodie Coppola
kayano fo Sato Sony or opiate respond
mandola Noonan Kobo son or go Leo so che
sia la liga sa participate di questo new
ovary Nascimento Rocio
from dr. Hsu lavoro su la libertad suis
pas police we dat they so totally new
feature a guard re Evo ta Ali Perot only
single oak insane so the only dawn ad on
you all modern order suit so no Permira
confer McCabe llamo governor Tobin in
questa Maisie
erbium waldo vieira de governor ancora
me leo me pro see my messy perk well
okay Mira guarda Ali bellow Nacional non
Gambia Nullah
la mia para la vallee peu de Sun dodgy
Valley pew devotee in me over sorry on
on shall Ave go in Casa mi averse REO el
partido Democratic am Al Gore are not o
commune provincial a Joanie a row APPA a
quindi amiability buddy continued
alloderm one governo a little Yanni on
caper que pensó espero glass Amedeo
apart et al governo de una no Superion :
cincuenta percent a queen di questo she
de la forza La Valle del enthusiasm oh
the and re Avanti initiative oh ah da
requests Amy emoji onii-san's a Sione
gratitude in earring Gracia mentee prima
de la luna de not err Sol gula to TiVo
one lavoro
turn a new feature a domani sonal
Minister L intend no guarantee receives
a request Oh splendid open sahaja dot o
una demostración ad or go leo d Donita a
diwali ad futuro in quia sempre credito
a quindi ringrazio
emilio needy italiani Hetchy on ome on o
dot Oeste falsi Grazia Mila